something had to cut tree branches a
compact that sounds a little scary
now I see the camera so I can't see an
apartment that's perfect for this video
I hadn't even say something did not no
no you know your life is different now
damn here is my mother Theresa oMG look
beautiful you can tell that there's a
slight discrepancy in our appearances
right now my mother is on a full face of
makeup hmm and I'm not that's because I
would on my Facebook and asked you guys
what kind of video you wanted me to
shoot with my mom and a lot of you said
you wanted her to do on your cup and all
of you said you wanted her to do my
makeup blindfolded oh yeah okay you're
going to do my makeup line folded you
don't even need that because without my
glasses you're blind you can't see a
bloody thing yeah I came back home to
New Jersey to celebrate my mom's
birthday and this is all the makeup that
I've brought with me I've laid it out
here try not to look too much added this
is the woman that taught me initially
how to do my make oh yeah I mean yeah
how else are Seventeen magazine
Louise great so ever goodness yeah I'm
now going here and trouble doing like in
my eyes where they're do I'm going to
blindfold you and you're going to talk
us through doing my makeup if you're
going to apply it
no you're going to apply it with a
blindfold on okay you're going to reach
out grab things and just put them on my
face and see what happens are you here
welcome to the Internet sorry to ruin
your already beautiful makeup that you
spent time applying Justin I just inches
I'm gonna have my [ __ ] on the carpet I
think I will probably have micronized -
how many fingers am i holding up
how should I know yes here's my face
free creating a scene from Helen Keller
right now still beautiful outfit yeah
I'm also sick so I could use some heavy
concealing here are you ready mom
sure okay let the games begin good time
reach out and touch stuff it's not a
problem
oh well hold on does it get the stuff
yes this is all part you're just about
to go wait you can I see this again no
that's like this is called a blindfold
makeup challenge the only worth is gonna
lose them just challenges me oh don't
worry about it too much I don't like it
and I can't confirm anything that you're
touching what I don't have 40 minutes of
tape your game not Martha okay that no
that's a huge stress exercise and I
didn't lose no where the couch it's good
that article is good you have to just
get it can be wrong
yeah that's what makes it funny when
you're wrong like you guys then you'll
never be a good youtuber oh my lord this
is where we find out where are all my
indecision comes but can you just like
is it is it lip I can't tell you
anything is it concealer you just have
to be confident in your choices this is
good but you're smelling it you know how
okay okay that's my face oh my god does
it feel it feels very um it has a
sensation it has a very strong sensation
I feel good enough it oh I can feel a
lot it's brought a lot did you in a dark
you're kissing my nose club a minute
I'll go over the zombie look thank you I
feel beautiful
is it you look amazing thank you what's
next I think I should just see minimal
like a good life so no women know the
sounds
make up I don't know I figured out what
that last product was just like oh you
are way more Debbie don't make excuses
you know I think it is so beautiful I
know really meaning everything I think
it out of that section right now why not
my mom liked it my the learning
disability okay oh it's very sensory
yeah I'm always talked about getting
facials mmm
you're like I'm being born again - you
don't care - you yeah no no no no I'll
get makeup wipes for you but we you can
be comfortable this is probably also
cheating but I just don't all the rest
of my makeup get covered in [ __ ]
at all no so you can go out now yeah no
oh okay what are you doing next what are
you trying to do now I'm not doing your
eyes now my hands are all wet
I think you okay taking a fun challenge
and making it very difficult it's not
fun for me it's kind of tough
no yeah okay doesn't wit it doesn't - it
does not wish to get Feltham at one
point oh well thank you okay Oh
curious placement choice doing how we're
doing a face powder oh that is it -
today they're beautiful urges thank you
for putting everything away
okay I think you should attempt I in
some way
you gotta do eyebrows at some point
eyebrows yeah you know that you and I
never leave the house top billing in our
eyebrows yeah is ours could be a yeah
you're born with them I'm telling you
you came out a little reduced fantastic
I like amazing
I think we're marking about the BOK
you're stalling you know that is like
that fight-or-flight instinct Lynch
flight experience Christmas mm-hmm oh
yes very soft touch yeah Oh feels like
it going for a cat I feral cat I not a
feral cat come on cat be had figure
Errol day was employed outside a Leland
one of the day on stop that deafening is
a feral cat
he was looking one utility active losing
self to our cat yeah that's affirm
we'll talk offline about feral cats
employed okay my eye for those of you oh
yes look is really coming together okay
what are we get what else do we have to
do gotta give my eyebrow man I have no
idea where that is no no I put this out
there but I don't want you to say I
bestow this on you yes I am okay stop
testing just Nicolas question no no
Renee don't need anything
oh you didn't do my eyebrows kid you're
being a real [ __ ] about this
I like Cupid really seriously yeah I
mean look I put some decoys out okay
okay if you guys didn't know the hot tip
for makeup this summer is this little
loop with your ear nose that so how do
you feel you feel done there anything
else you want to do I would like to be I
just don't wanna hurt you okay so I'm
gonna call it a look while you take off
your blindfold and check out the magic
that you've worked on my face
welcome back Wow get readjusted yeah
it's not a special Joker mustache is the
file up right
oh uh yeah I could come in that makeup
or I'm very like a French clown oh yes
I'm more of a gifted I thought no one
would ever know that I am under the
weather right now oh thank you mom for
being part of this video I hope you guys
enjoyed it welcome everyone wish my
mom's happy birthday thank you Nabisco
created video tell me that if you
enjoyed it and leave a comment down
below what do you call this makeup look
so we're gonna subscribe to this YouTube
channel and make videos Monday Wednesday
Friday sometimes other than that I don't
know what do you call this look I call
it the pre cat musical oh this is like
the rough draft of the cat Roy okay
Isaac all like I would be like it's
something like this but there'll be more
of it yeah